let's kind of get into the speculative
stuff a little bit I want to play this
um BBC special that aired last night it
was radio only uh it's about 36 minutes
long if you guys can do me a solid I'm
just going to drop the link in YouTube
because I only monitor the chat in
YouTube so if you're watching this on
Facebook Twitter twatch you know
wherever uh click that link that I just
dropped in all chat head over to use
YouTube hit the like button thumbs up
um And subscribe obviously so you don't
miss anything because I'll keep an eye
on the chat on YouTube if you guys have
any questions uh for us as we're doing
this or anything you want us to address
as we're kind of going through this
um so let's throw this in the Stream
here and I've checked the audio if you
guys have any issues with the audio
while it's playing you let me know
um I think we'll be able to run through
through this at about 1.2 times speed
and still understand it we'll kind of
pause along the way so if there's
something that you want to hit on just
just hit just say pause and I'll just
hit the pause button and then we'll kind
of discuss it and then we'll just go and
resume it so we'll just play the song
yeah before we start broadly speaking I
mean this documentary was um produced by
an individual called
um Paul Kenyan I think his name is and
someone called Haley now first of all
Paul's been writing a significant amount
of things on Twitter
which no problem he's trying to
advertise his show but one of the points
he makes is this he says from the
information well he makes two points
first he says there's a in this audio
that you're going to listen to there's a
treasure Trove of information so
listening to it I was expecting massive
Bombshells I was expecting things which
would be unbelievable and he claimed
that this would be the reason or or an
example or an example of why the tits
are going to be convicted so I'll allow
that your audience to see if they come
to the same conclusion and the second
issue is he said that
according to the information he has the
tear Brothers Are Gonna remain in prison
till May five weeks before the 180 days
I run out and then the trial will start
immediately now when I read that I have
two questions the first question is
you've stated that unequivocally so it's
not you said my opinion you've said it
it's gonna happen
so if that's the case and you and you
it's one of two things either you're
inaccurate and you're just talking
nonsense or the other option is you have
inside information the concern with that
is if you have inside information
that again goes to the idea of the
Matrix and these brothers or the
Judgment already been decided because
remember they're meant to be having a
hearing every 30 days the prosecution
are meant to be presenting the evidence
they're going to be presenting the
defense and then the judge makes a
decision then most likely they'll appeal
that decision so in up until May there
should be six Court hearings so is he
saying those Court Havens are fall down
conclusion so those are the two issues
that I can communicate before we listen
to it and then the third thing is if you
look at the narrative it'll be it's very
one-sided and quite biased they were
just my comments before we start
yeah um you'll get a general feel for
what the BBC's done with this once we
start playing through it because a lot
of the um
the proof uh didn't didn't really seem
to be there when I was listening to and
I listened to it twice this morning to
you know take a few notes so let me uh
throw it back up on the screen again you
know if there's something that you want
to pause and discuss just let me know
just just say pause and I'll pause it
and then we'll uh hop into it
um all right let's go back in here and
put this back up in the screen
uh okay and let's hit play and again if
you guys have any issue with the audio
just let me know and I'll and I'll make
some adjustments
uh come on let's play there we go I am
by the metrics of the internet the most
famous individual who is currently alive
in the world today Andrew Tate a
self-proclaimed misogynist who says he's
a trillionaire and who's followed
a huge digital Army of young men the
Youth of today well
straight first point they start with
this idea of self-proclaimed misogynist
is to create the narrative that guess
what he is a misogynist and it's based
on what he said now I had an interaction
with somebody from the New York Post his
name was Joshua and I forgot his surname
and he started and said look I'm writing
an article about the self-proclaimed
misogynist Andrews here so I asked him I
said look what can you provide me for
the reference for that statement
so he said no problem and then he
provided me with a link to the BBC so I
said to him look that's not a primary
source can you provide me for the
information for a primary source so he
sent me a podcast
and so I'll listen to the podcast and
that irony is in the podcast Andrew says
you guys call me a misogynist because
you guys are zombified and you guys are
brainwashed by The Matrix just call me a
misogynist but I'm not so he says the
opposite in that so there may be some
other clip
but they've not been able to provide it
so in in reality they're all copied each
other about this statement and no one
actually knows the original source of
the statement
yeah I've I've heard him use
use it in a
um
a self-deprecating almost comical way
you know like it's like it's clear to me
when I hear him use that
um or he's addressing it he's he's just
making fun of it like I'm the last
person that you should consider a
misogynist I take care of women I have a
family you know I raise children sort of
thing I look after the you know the
people that I love I've retired my
mother
um so but it's as long as I don't
believe in comedy that's the problem
yeah everything when you don't like
someone everything's literal yeah you
know they'll take everything literally
and that's what they do right like they
go looking for sound bites you know it
it becomes a Witch Hunt and to me this
this does seem like a Witch Hunt
um should we carry on yeah yes all right
let's go
don't listen to anybody else that's the
reason I'm the most famous man on the
planet because none of these other
people have the authority to affect them
like I do his videos have been viewed
more than 12 billion times online
boasting about his lavish lifestyle and
urging men to toppen up and take control
of women Life Is War it's a war for the
female you want it's a war for the car
you want it's a war for the money you
want it's a war for the status if you're
a man who doesn't view life as War
you're going to lose I'm Paul Kenyon I
specialize in exposing criminality and
have family in Romania where Tate's
Empire prospered and I'm Georgia Cohn
I'm from the same town as Tate Luton I
know the same neighborhoods and some of
the same people my mum even grew up on
the same Council estate Marsh Farm we're
doing this investigation together
because Tate's alpha male Ultra
masculine message is aimed at young men
and his violent misogyny is something
women like me find out
yep it's a very short comment violent
misogyny so where's the evidence for the
last statement so again you've thrown a
statement out which sounds completely
horrendous violent misogyny where's the
evidence for violent misogyny so you're
going to see through this piece I've
highlighted this point where they'll
make statements like these without ever
backing it up with any evidence or data
are they are they making a reference to
the video clip of uh Andrew back in the
day when he was quite a bit younger
where he was filmed beating a woman with
a belt
um it was you know revealed afterwards
that that was consensual on both sides
and you know some people are into that
like is that what they're trying to
amplify at this stage do you think well
we don't know because not provide any
evidence they do refer to that that
issue later so we will go into detail
about that when they bring it out okay
let's carry on
extremely offensive my course about Tate
is being held in a Romanian prison over
allegations of human trafficking and
rape
he said it's all a setup by what he
calls The Matrix a conspiracy of the
Rich and Powerful to shut him up
hopefully tonight Fallout 4 has an
exclusive interview with a British woman
who says that she was controlled and
abused by Andrew Tate it was just
constantly feeling inferior to him I
realized I just couldn't live like that
anymore and it wasn't normal
and I'm flying sorry I just want to
pause on that for a moment here because
I think it's relevant like you know one
of the sound bites that they drop in
here several times throughout the cast
is I felt in fear to him like I
constantly felt inferior to him well I
mean if you're a woman and you're and
you're dating a guy that's
massive I mean he's you know he's a
giant he's six foot two six foot three
he's a retired kickboxer he's got lots
of money it's it's hard to feel Superior
to a guy like that so why is this being
Amplified you know it's a question that
I have like you know I feel inferior to
Elon Musk right I mean me stating that
does that mean that Elon Musk is a
violent misogynist you know towards me
you see what I'm driving at it's an
excellent point because someone's
thought process of feeling inferior
inferior he should never have a basis I
would say the significant reasons I
think you'll get a prime example but
there's significant reasons and
psychology that causes one to feel
inferior I would say uh being Asian
coming from the United Kingdom you have
this kind of inferiority complex where
you're trying to think trying hard
they're trying to prove yourself harder
does that mean that now entire Society
has caused that to happen probably not
so
um yeah there's significant issues I I
totally agree with what you said all
right let's carry on to Romania to ask
whether his boasts of vast wealth are
all that they seem and what lies behind
his network of companies
or having seen the information that
you've shown me it is quite hard to
differentiate that from other networks
I've seen would have ultimately ended up
being shown to be money ordering or
other Financial criminal Networks
tonight the shocking story behind one of
the world's most infamous social media
stars and how he became an icon of young
men looking for fast money fast girls
and internet Stars
[Music]
I'll give it to him this is a
well-produced audio piece the sound
everything it's spot on like they're
they're definitely driving at something
here right yeah yeah he's good and also
uh he's a very good narrator like he
knows how to use his attitude elocution
at the right yeah points to get his
point across
it's a cold morning in January and I'm
on my way to see a young woman with an
important story to tell
she's Angie Tate's ex-girlfriend and
she's decided to give her first
interview to follow uncle
I think that's her actually because I
recognize her from her pictures
I'm meeting her in a car park of a
Motorway service station because she's
scared and doesn't feel comfortable to
let us visit her at home she asked if we
can talk in my car
we're going to call her Sophie
she's worried about possible online
backlash from Tate's followers her words
are spoken by an actor
so first there's two points here the
first thing is that the same the
dramatizing since she's too scared she's
gonna meet in the car park but the later
on Twitter they said she's the seventh
victim now so she's seasonally added to
the case if she's added the kiss she's
not going to be anonymous she's gonna
have to go to court she's going to have
to be questioned she's going to have to
be cross-examined so again it's
providing drama when in reality there's
no drama basis for that drama because
she's she's going to be coming out
publicly that's the first point and the
second thing is that after that
is playing the woman and what you'll see
is I'll have some comments about that
later but just to highlight your
audience so this is an actor now it's
not an actual woman who does this
talking or crying
yeah they've used a voice actor to
um I guess just read the lines that she
stated so yeah I mean I mean that's a
question so if it does that so if
there's like certain parts in there
that's that the voice actor cries and
shows emotion so now is that based on a
script where the script is telling her
to cry or was she there when the
interview is occurring so in your
experience what do you think
yeah I guess we'll find out when we
listen to this
River let us know because we can do that
okay thank you
she arrives we're in a black fur coat
looking flawless
she's nervous her hands are shaking as
she speaks it's very difficult because
I don't feel like a victim I mean all
the choices I made were of my free will
he didn't you know bundle me up in a bag
throw me in the back of a lorry and
drive me there but yeah
I mean do we need any comments she
literally States the whole thing and
just demonstrates why this isn't
trafficking she basically it was my free
will it was my choice he didn't force me
to go
yeah
um that's not going to serve them in
court will it
I don't think it will anyway I mean
we'll see yeah Romanian court system you
know receives something like that but if
I was on the defense side I would
definitely use that I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full-length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out